you can go through the course and you
can think okay this this makes logical
sense this makes logical sense this may
so but then there could be one thing
that you say or somebody says and it's
like okay now
we can actually really do this i think
this is actually a really good example
because this is an education that's
really relevant to life
and it helps people live their passion i
think the current model of education is
very um
demoralizing for most kids
and it doesn't serve their passion i
said to him i'll be in the room with you
if you want or i can come out and he was
like no i don't want you in the room
because it's gonna be a bit embarrassing
or whatever i stepped out and i heard
him he said hello my name is yousef
green and i'm a property investor and i
was like oh my little 15 year old
oh thank you guys so much for coming to
my house and sharing the story we've got
a lot in common with property and kids
um how did you guys meet and when did
you first get into property so we met
through charity so we worked we um
our passion is like teaching so i'm a
teacher and we also look into alternate
alternative sources of education so we
we
use them as a maria montessori course
model and we've we established a school
from ground up so first of all was
homeschooling so my my children my uh
eldest children they were home schooled
and then a group of homeschoolers came
together and we created a school and uh
and we're part of an organization called
like the alameda institute and we we
kind of
we uh create we made a school so we
stayed at the school and uh we did a lot
of charity work together and we met
through charity and when we first met
when you're on the academy which has
been great but you know i know your kids
were a massive driving force for you
wanting to be successful in property so
um and now your kids are in property as
well which is which is amazing so what
was your when did you decide you wanted
to get into property how did that come
about so i've always been
reluctant about committing to property
because i felt like it was something
that sort of limits you
holds you down
doesn't allow you to explore and enjoy
and you sort of the traditional ideas
about what property does you don't get
tied to a mortgage for 25 years and that
kind of idea yeah and do you think
that's part of islam as well because i
know um
debt is it is a is it is it so mortgages
are you know some people sort of uh
have different different opinions about
mortgages and there are assignment
mortgages that you can explore which is
obviously what matthew's been looking at
um but um
i was just really skeptical about it i
didn't like the idea of being tied down
um
and so i've always been reluctant but
through sort of
realizing that you know investing
and the growth that property offers you
um sort of i've been sort of dragged
into it um a little bit reluctantly but
um i'm starting to see the benefits of
it and the security that's important and
i think once i got married and had
children i started to understand
um
you know why owning your own space and
having that that you can pass on to your
children so there's not always this
um
insecurity about where you're gonna live
that's the instability there i think
that's something that matthew got right
from the beginning um so he's always
been quite quite sort of firm on that so
you know wanting to make sure there's
something secure for the children
there's something there that you can
pass on so they can actually grow and
develop rather than every generation
starting from scratch
that's interesting that you have this
idea of you know property was
enslavement entrapment and that's really
interesting because most people i don't
think think that at all normally
property represents freedom and and
passive income and legacy but that's
interesting i think is that's what
that's what i understood you know at the
time um and there's sort of kind of
25 years you're tied down to this
mortgage
and it was just like oh my gosh and
you've got pay off this sort of
traditional understandings of debt and
yeah and commitment and things like that
and there's a lot of truth in in i mean
debt is can entrap you and enslave you
absolutely um what was your as again as
as a muslim matthew
how did you get around the issue of debt
because i get asked the question over
and over by people you know what can we
do we want to get into property want to
buy properties but we're our religion is
against taking out any debt could you
say anything on that yeah so um what i
did is i didn't get a mortgage for many
many many many years and um i just what
i did i put a ad in the mosque so i knew
i wanted a property so i put an ad in
the mask anybody interested in
buying a property with me then just call
this number so they called the number
and uh there was two people came
straight away uh i actually knew these
people they went to my uh old school or
something and um we put our money
together so in terms of like you could
do joint ventures instead of to raise
the funds yeah yeah yeah so in instead
of doing um
you doing it by yourself and waiting
like 10 years saving up the money it's
it's easier to three people putting
their money or four people putting their
money together and actually getting the
25 themselves so usually a buy to let is
25 down and if you're putting 25 down
and three other people put him 25 down
then you can actually effectively just
buy the property all three of you bought
the property no mortgage yes and there's
a opinion that you can have islamic
mortgages for your your first house and
there are islamic mortgages that you can
that you can use yeah and
so those are ways so there are ways
potentially around it
um
so now today fast forward however many
years you are both well you're for you
don't have jobs anymore you're full-time
in property yes that's right and you're
making um a passive income of about
three to four thousand pounds a month
yeah but for profit three grand a month
easy easily and uh yeah so that's
absolutely incredible well well massive
congrats on what you've done is your
perspective about property change
somewhat now it has what's your
perspective now about i think because
sort of my whole idea about work is that
work should be something that serves
what you actually want to do
and if you're working nine to five and
then over time you're actually just
working and you're part of this cog in
the world you're not able to do what you
actually want to do you can't live your
passion yeah and then by the time you
can live your passion when your
retirement comes through you're too old
to do anything with it really um so if
if this is something that can allow that
can free you up to actually do what you
want to do then that's phenomenal and i
think also for me which was really quite
powerful is i think that
people being
autonomous and
working setting up their own businesses
and experiencing what it feels like to
be in charge and responsible
and making decisions rather than just
being under somebody
um and i think feeling that kind of
hope and fear
is the money going to come through this
month or is it not having a bit of
instability in your life is quite
exciting
right um and it keeps you on the edge it
keeps you appreciative but you don't
think you don't take things for granted
you know the paycheck is going to come
in every month whether i turn up at
school or not you know
it's there you've gotten the whole other
extreme now yeah i think i'll be i'm a
bit whack on though this is the other
extreme but that yeah what um your play
a big role in the in the property
business i know you manage the the
service accommodation side of the
business how is that because we've just
moved and we're trying to unpack boxes
while respond to guests while sort out
rates and then feed the children it's a
bit manic and mad but it's still doable
yeah
and it's been like kind of
i'm just thinking when this is a little
bit more settled this is actually really
really going to be a passive income
right because we're trying to put the
systems in place and you know at the
beginning we've been quite involved so
initially the first couple of days we
went down ourselves and took the
took the uh
the bed sheets and the linen to the
laundry ourselves and you know matthews
up all night ironing them or whatever
because i was like i'm not doing it
but now we've got a cleaner in we've got
a laundret that kind of does the ironing
for us you know we're starting to sort
of put things in place and see that
actually this could be really and then
and the the cleaner's really good she
sort of kind of itemized the whole
cupboard herself and figured out when
things to be replenished so it's really
like
looking like it's going to be very
hands-off
your biggest complaint um is that you're
having too many bookings yeah that was
my complaint like we just got one the
other day and i was like oh man
another one yeah she's saying should we
just leave the gap like i was
gonna lower the lower the price for the
the uh because we had a gap where where
all week was booked apart from two days
yeah you're saying uh she's like she
worked should i just lower the price
down so we're gonna go please can we
just no i don't have to wanna have to
deal with like another message let's
just have two days off um but actually
it is becoming a lot easier
and less hands-on and even what it has
been has been manageable within this
sort of crazy period where we're moving
unpacking yeah settling down you know
half the time we don't know where the
charger is for the laptop you know it's
kind of like that and we're still
managing it so i think when it's when
you're in this kind of like a normal
why does it need to be passive though
because if you've quit your jobs and if
you're literally full-time property i
know you've got kids and stuff but why
does it need to be 100 passive that's
because i we haven't used passion as
property
mine is educational i want to develop
resources and really start thinking
about developing models and things like
right and working on that so he's
brought you on to manage it but then to
also systemize it and make it completely
passive yeah that makes sense so you
guys have got properties as well i know
you've kind of operated a little bit all
over the place you've packaged and sold
a deal in liverpool
you've helped your children buy a
property in leeds that was really
interesting yeah you've got a property
just outside of london which is service
accommodation so when you're looking to
get a property deal
how do you choose where to go
how do you find an area that's good
that's the big question and i think
going on like the academy or your course
that really really helps narrow it down
so there's so many different strategies
that you can use to generate money in
property but um when you when you go and
you and i i was like what should i do
like where should i go where's my patch
where's my area and then when you sit
down with someone like yourself or
someone like tony one of the mentors on
the course
it really he can you can really use your
experience and your expertise to kind of
fine-tune what is going to be your
strategy for this moment in time because
this is what you need
you need cash flow or you need you know
you need to be financially free first
and then when you're financially free
then looking at when you were talking
about the essays
on the course and looking at picking an
area that is like 45 minute drive from
you so you can just go out go outside of
london the m25 which is close to your
area and find a place like cambridge or
play a place like harlow or a place like
just outside of that area then um that
that's what you should be doing first
that as far as i'm concerned right yeah
yeah looking around where you actually
live
um talk to me about your children oh my
days okay so on the course i was just
like pee pee pee pee
a flash moment here because like you can
you can
you can go through the course and you
can think okay this this makes logical
sense this makes logical sense this may
so but then there could be one thing
that you say or somebody says and it's
like okay now
we can actually really do this so one of
the things is my my daughter's renting
and she's uh in leeds she's graduated in
uh these university with the first and
she was living in some
accommodation um
when she's paying rent but why should
she pay rent she could actually own the
house or own the house or or uh control
the house and make money from the house
herself so we just we
we just we strategized we told them what
to say just used all the things from the
course and how to get a book in how to
view the house how to find a server how
what is the best uh roi and all of these
things and we we sat down and we
schooled them happy kids and how to do
that and they actually just went up
there and we went up there together
slept on the floor and then we
we got our offer accepted on a few
houses not even one just a few houses we
picked the best one and um in in at the
end of the month it stairs you know you
remember there was one house i didn't go
up i was just watching from the
sidelines because it was interesting
watching all the the arguments that were
going on as well between the kids you're
already putting this much in why should
you get that much rent out and then
figuring out the percentages and things
like that but there was one house that
they said um they were like oh dad you
know that house next to that um
castle next to the castle and we were
talking about his house next to the
class and they were telling me about i
said if it's next to a castle that's
really good you're going to get like
tourists and it's really nice and then
we actually caught they called up and
they inquired about it a bit further and
they realized it was a prism
[Laughter]
in the prison that's hilarious it helped
them decide that you know sort of like
we don't want to be around a prison we
want to be near a castle so it was nice
for them to sort of realize the
importance of location for example and
how old are the kids that bought the
house so uh my four oldest which is 26
25 20 23
uh
20 and 16.
yes and the 16 year old were on the
phone as well yeah the 16 year old was
they they had to all he was 15 at the
time and what happened
when he was on the phone so we gave him
a script okay you say hello i'm a
property investor blah blah blah and
he's 15 years old he's a boy that means
boys don't want to talk on the phone
yeah he's a teenager he said dad i
wouldn't have to do this and the oldest
one was like if he doesn't call make
calls and he cut he's got to do what
i've got to do i've got make calls he's
going to make sure he's not in there on
the deal yeah if he i'm putting money
he's got put him money so they were like
you know the same kind of sibling stuff
going on and he was so reluctant it was
the last day and i heard him i said to
him i'll be in the room with you if you
want or i can come out and he was like
no no i don't want you in the room
because it's gonna be a bit embarrassing
or whatever i stepped out and i heard
him he said hello my name is yousef
green and i'm a property investor and i
was like oh my little 15 year old
oh goodness can i have a booking um can
i you know can i view this property and
you kind of fumbled it up a little bit
but you kind of you know managed to get
through you put the phone down i was
like you did it and it's like
yeah well you know i just couldn't
believe that you
well you know what that's brilliant
teaching your kids to step out of their
car and i guess this is where it ties in
with property and also education so
you're wanting what is it that you're
wanting to change in the education
system
oh gosh
that's a long conversation
i think i think this is actually a
really good example because this is an
education that's really relevant to life
and it helps people live their passion i
think
the current model of education
is very um
demoralizing for most kids yeah
and it doesn't serve their passion you
know they're they're 12 they're 13 they
don't want to sit in school for 15 hours
six seven hours a day doing math science
in english because that's what you told
them to do you know they might have
another interest
so
the big thing behind montessori
education and her big sort of um her way
was that you follow the child's interest
because children naturally want to learn
and i think when we start thinking that
they don't want to learn that we have to
make them learn that's when they resist
learning
um and then you have in the standard
state school system you have you know
the top sets the middle average kids and
you have the foundation sets if you're
in a foundation set you're just
you're just a number so you're you're a
negative number so you automatically say
to yourself that i'm rubbish because
you're in that class you know you're in
the foundation so everyone knows you're
in the foundation
it means something that isn't gonna it's
not good for yourself it's not gonna
build you as a human being and you
didn't come here to be crushed well when
i was in school you know you know you
know this i mean i sat on a special
needs desk and was told basically that
was stupid absolutely yeah um and then
ended up being worth 20 million
yeah
myself too i was in special i was in
special needs class too what was wrong
with you what
nothing yeah that's the point right
that's the point wrong
that's what you say to yourself yeah
that's a classic example what is wrong
with me yeah and even now i'm a teacher
and i've done a good degree whatever i
still believe i'm stupid because that's
what
was told to you at a very young age
you're not worthy now because you're
worth 20 million you're worthy because
you're samuel yeah and you could lose
your 20 million pounds tomorrow and
you're still worthy yeah like you know
that's really important that we don't
attach worth to
like degree status or education or gcse
results or or money it's like
building that your self-worth as a human
being regardless of whether you have
stuff to validate yourself you know what
though i've always been good at making
money yeah but they didn't spot that
when i was a kid i found that i'm good
at making money so for me my money it's
not my worth but it's how i keep the
score no but absolutely and the thing is
is that i'm a traditional teacher
trained teacher and so is matthew but
you're teaching and you're educating
people and you're teaching them about
self-worth and help helping them be in
the world and this guy and you've been
trained formally at all this guy this
education isn't limited to like you know
that kind of that kind of thing it's
bigger than that and when we limit it
like that then it just limit people
you know so
with samuel like he came into the room
the first time he came because i didn't
i'm not really big on youtube you first
came into the room and everyone was
standing up yeah samuel i was like what
are you standing up for okay like i'm
not you have to earn my respect for me
to stand up
by the end of the course i swear i was
crying i was crying this guy like like
he changes lives and i say i said to you
he does more for black life matters yeah
because of who he is and who his wife is
and uh and like
then the whole school system the whole
of england and he you you when you said
when you said um for example
um
[Music]
we know you want to build a school and
you want to have a curriculum for you if
i build a school you're going to have a
financial curriculum in my school
you're going to have a financial growing
teach these kids how to be financially
free so that they can do what they want
in the world to make a big difference in
the world yeah right and you know what
having that having that drive as well
having a reason and like you're the same
as me we've got a bigger it's not just
about i'm trying to make the money it's
actually
property gives us freedom choices time
to do what you know and for me having a
training company is a mission for me um
and i think you know for you guys it's
it's it's very very very similar what
what what is it that when they go and
gets tough because i know in property
it's not all rosy there's times when you
feel like quitting or oh this is really
you bad ten bad guests um you know how
do you deal with those hard times upon
your mum your phone i phone your mum
and people like tony yeah it's like okay
yes you can breathe again and then you
can and and and everybody on the course
they're at different levels so there's
people just flying and you and there's
when people are uh
behind thinking ah i'll never get there
blah blah blah but when you share ideas
with all of these people and then and
then you you can bring them in because
they've got all the the desire they've
got all the the push they've got the
time yeah they have the time yeah or
they've got the skills there's some of
them it's just amazing one girl i met
like i don't know how to do social media
she was like okay i'll i'll teach you i
said yes yes yes so she showed me how to
do the social media and put me on the
platform and if she ever needs anything
from me i'm i'm yeah so that networking
that team that team building yeah that
environment that is so so so important
to keep you when you're going to go down
yeah right you're going to have periods
when things are not working for you or
you've got other things that you have to
do
to do what you want to do
and then you lose the plot a little bit
but then when you reconnect with these
people and you know yeah that's amazing
i think you thought that he was
insulting me when i said how do you deal
with tough days your mom
[Laughter]
right
so they look really
how long have you been in property
because i know when we met you've got
some experience in property you've
obviously now scaled up and you've and
you've systemized things and you're
working a bit smarter but when did you
first get into property when did you
first buy an investment house so that
was when i was uh
probably about
apart from my knowledge it would have
been like
it was 16 17 years ago yeah something
because you paid off the the something
which was like 15 years long wasn't it
and then you just paid it off yeah it
finished
so why why did you join the academy
because i knew that if i want to fulfill
my dream because i want to build a
school we want to buy a school like in
london which is going to cost maybe at
least like one and a half million if i
if i don't um
put if i don't have people a network of
people where i can uh
share my ideas with growth
um
help direct me in the right property
direction then it's not it's not going
to happen
even the contracts alone
you know the
even the contracts alone is like worth
the money you know and would you enjoy
the contract so like if you're going to
do a uh
for example a lease option agreement
because a good way of buying the school
would be doing a lease option agreement
you know so you get the like
and then uh and if you don't do the
contracts right and you don't have the
resources to do the contracts right then
you could instead of making x amount of
money you're going to lose a wide amount
of money and that just just doesn't make
any sense sure i'll see you in on the
academy having access to the contract
for work and stuff is
yeah yeah well you're dealing you sold a
deal in liverpool how much did you make
on that three and a half
three and a half like it's nothing you
know like back but again to do that you
need contracts yeah totally which you
had access to yeah which you had access
to yeah um and it's the confidence once
you've got the contracts and you've got
the
mentors it gives you the confidence to
just move forward otherwise i'll be like
oh should i do this this is my last
3 000 if i don't have that then i can't
pay for this and but okay let's go let's
do it how much profit are your kids
making on their house what were the
figures on that they're going to make
they're going to make i i haven't told
them but they're going to make like a at
least 1 200. nice at least and the
daughter that's living there
she's going to be living rent-free
basically right i thought that was the
agreement though she's the manager she's
the valuable she has to pay half red oh
okay okay because it's all theirs yeah
so it's gonna everything's gonna be
theirs and so it's not fair that she
just lives there but it's basically set
them up for life though yeah and skills
it's huge yeah it's it's incredible and
i'm sure that's the first of many
problems yeah they will be they're going
to be much better than
me
what would be your advice to somebody
um
wanting to get into property
what would be your best advice
i would i would i would say
um
that's a good question
i would say
you must get into property first of all
yeah don't think about not getting in
make a decision
and if you you're short on finances look
at the area look at yourself look at
your environment okay so you you live in
a if you live in a a house and there's a
spare room in your house
rent that spare room out you know rent
that experience so get to get get get
the knowledge yeah and use your
environment that you're in so at least
you like get the knowledge in terms of
if you want to do a rental rent or you
want to do a hmo or renter get the
knowledge okay get the knowledge get the
contracts and just get the environment
and march forward yeah yeah
i love that about being resourceful as
well thinking what have i currently got
also who do i currently know like the
guy that you sold that deal to that
wasn't anybody even on the academy that
was just somebody that you knew
you know so you found the deal on the
training and then you thought who do i
know that might want to deal like this
and then bang three and a half grand
you're so resourceful
um you know what's been the biggest
learning curve then for yourself
i think
just trusting
trusting that the the just go with the
process because the interest that we've
had in the in the service accommodation
has been like overwhelming
yeah like
i was so skeptical about matthew
i you know when he when he when he told
me how much money he put down for the
academy i was like oh my gosh
he came home that evening i said we're
trying to buy a house i'm going to have
no new carpets or furniture i was like
oh my gosh i can't believe he's done
that but i thought you know what you
can't crush somebody he's gotta live his
passion you gotta let people do what
they need to do okay i'm gonna let him
make his mistakes i was being very
generous let him make his mistakes i'm
not gonna say i told you so and then
suddenly i'm having to like eat my words
internally because i didn't say out loud
well i might have a few times we had a
disagreement
and i'm thinking oh shame
oh my gosh we've got a booking and
another one another people are paying
that much money to live here like really
you know so i've been really pleasantly
surprised um
at how doable it is and how um
i i think just being sort of one over to
the idea i think what matthew's really
important that
you must invest in something that's
substantial and that doesn't make sense
having money sitting in the bank when it
can just sit in a home and growing and
again even that sort of traditional
mindset if you know if you can't afford
where you are if you're in london or a
big city then there are other places
that you could
buy and they'll grow and you can serve
other people by allowing them to live
there in a nice space at a reasonable
rent it serves them and it serves you
because you've got growth
at a price that's more affordable for
you yeah yeah so just really thinking
outside the box
um
yeah property's been a really good
education for me to really think outside
of the box and sort of think in
non-traditional ways
um
so yeah and it's been really fun
actually because you know doing the
house up i got to do i've got some
creative license on the essay and doing
it up and it was really it was really it
was fun actually makes it look really
beautiful i can imagine yeah it was fun
doing that up and being quite creative
like um we
i'm really into being resourceful you
know upcycling and things like that but
i also wanted things to be nice
and also you've got to sort of think
about the kind of average market of what
people's taste is like and so it was
nice so being able to put myself in
other people's shoes um looking at um
places like gumtree and facebook
marketplace for things that were new or
people were selling um because they're
moving or whatever but it's in like new
condition or nearly new and thinking
that that could be really nice actually
and so even with our place now where
we've moved i don't think we've actually
bought anything in our own house that's
brand new
we've we've we've looked at things that
are like um
being sold the brand new that people are
selling or things like that so it feels
like you're kind of supporting people
even in your purchasing yeah yeah and
it's not just going to sit in landfill
or go and sit in you know dump somewhere
it's actually being moved around and
used in really nice ways and then you
get a sort of a wider spread of what you
can actually purchase um and look at
because it's quite yeah it's been really
interesting and what's the total
bookings what's the revenue per month i
know you're making three grand a month
profit but what what's the revenue i
think
minimum five five right yeah that's a
lot of bookings
and what's the average room room per
night then so we just do the whole house
and we're probably 250 250 at night and
who are these people are they like
tourists or contractors or relocators
all of them right we haven't we haven't
got a relocator yet no we had one
tourist
um the people that just left this
morning were from australia
um
people from china from hong kong we have
another australians coming next week
we've had someone from romania coming um
but we also had the the contractors i
didn't realize they were contractors
that was a good learning experience
actually they came for four days in the
week tuesday to friday i was wondering
who's that you know four days tuesday to
fight it's unusual and then on friday
they're messaging me saying um do you
mind if we stay a bit longer because our
work's still
ongoing
and i was like i know because we had a
booking right at the beginning of the
week and it actually wasn't a real
booking it was we'd basically blocked
off that
two days for a family
family member to stay because they were
traveling and we were like yeah we lost
the amma she lose
a thousand pounds
just by letting someone and we thought
what should we do and is this old
elderly uncle we thought no we can't
tell him no because he was so looking
forward to living at this nice place
yeah shame oh we're just gonna have to
take the hair drop him and invoke it
we just took the hit and said sorry
we're booked out for next week we
haven't got the we haven't got the
availability but what we realized was
that if we get a contractor because they
were electrical people we should
actually ask them
at the at the onset if you need to
extend let us know so we can like block
off for you yeah because that was a nice
secure booking and it would have just
continued and they were you know they
were nice clean so i hope your uncle's
watching this now
we didn't tell him he didn't know
it's nice to be able to provide
accommodation for your family yeah is a
nice thing what um
matthew what's the plan from here then
like what's the what's the goal now so
um financial freedom means more space
and time to move so i need to i need to
like maybe brrs yeah lease option
agreement or land yeah so if i'm gonna
we're gonna build this school create
enough money though i think those are
the money
those are the
great so now you've got financial
freedom you want to now create wealth
yeah to then give you money to be able
to really fund the things and it's so
good because you can help everybody
like you don't need you don't need
i'm going to take maybe a small
token but if i know people with my
family my friends and you're just going
to advise them you know you're going to
like why are you doing that why are you
paying off your whole mortgage for
what's wrong with you
do this this this yeah or whatever you
can you've got
you can help people in so many different
ways yeah what how do you know when an
area is going to work well on service
accommodation how are you so confident
about this particular property and how
did you yeah we went through your course
so i thought even i didn't know but when
after going through the course it's got
a hotel nearby like hot spot yeah
there's a hotel around the corner then
it's like uh is there uh
transport links okay is it is can you
get contractors in oh they're building
so many things over there it's like all
of the boxes were kind of like yeah
ticked and it's like
thing you know it's gonna work it's just
it's a process isn't it it's like it's
like any skill or art it's not luck it's
not guessing it's just following the
process and when you once you like
once you do the course it gives you
confidence to move otherwise the
confidence is a big thing i think you
didn't like theoretically know things
but
that sort of energy he came back with i
was like well initially it was like he
stopped now
yeah irresponsible
remember that money you paid um but um
slowly you realize that actually that's
what it is when you have this passion
you attract positivity to yourself and
it becomes positive and it's like that
gratitude kind of mindset yeah it's
positive because
he's around me and the guys making money
doing deals he's like whoa
you know everyone's getting home pumped
um what was it that made you agree to
come and do this interview
i was a bit uh i wasn't sure i'm
generally i generally set the fence on
most things so i have to you know um and
i thought matthew matthew was like um
you know it'd be good you're the ones
actually doing a lot of the work with
setting things up and you can get a good
give a good insight into what it's
actually like
um and also i think would be i thought
it would be good in terms of
we are a team yeah so we represented as
a team oh yeah
you have to we got a spiritual kind of
teacher and she you had that i asked him
i said is it going to be good for me to
go or is it better for me not to go and
he said yeah go yeah so um i wanted to
have that go ahead like is it is it good
to go is it is it good for my growth is
it good for whoever's going to benefit
so hopefully well i'm so glad that you
did because there's i'm sure there's
going to be people watching that might
be able to relate to you in many ways
that couldn't necessarily relate to me
and coming on and being a light and sort
of stepping out i'm really glad that you
came today thank you for having us yeah
and and matthew it's been a blast man
what's it been like working together
over the last six months you uh like
it's the transport because
like i said before i i couldn't even
stand up for you before it was just like
like just like just he'd be telling me
stuff and crying i'd be like oh my gosh
you know the the last the last the last
thing we went and you did the you did it
was the council the council uh the the
late two girls were council tenants and
they were they got the right to buy yeah
and then you you offered them a way out
in terms of okay because
from now you know they they're gonna be
fine they could be like to be a pro to
go from not being a property owner to
being a property owner
that's just going to change your life
and generational wealth because
otherwise you're just trapped forever
yeah i remember i remember yeah there
was a a lady that
had the right to barbie didn't couldn't
pay the legal fees and i was just like
i'll pay oh wow because it was just like
literally she has massive discount but
that little small thousand pounds
was just not letting her um but the
breakthroughs are happening amazing and
matthew again that's very generous of
you well no it was a small gesture but
it's the kind of thing that happens and
again they're all students they're all
in there my attitude is you know i want
to help as many people as i can but when
people invest like obviously matthew
join the account when people invest in
themselves it kind of gives me
a permission to be able to invest in
them sure okay you know so it's been a
blast and i'm really pleased and proud
of what you've done and i know it's just
the start but more than what you're
doing what you're doing for the for the
next generation and showing back into
the generation you know massive respect
and uh thank you for sharing and thank
you for being an asset to the community
[Music]
you